Cause you hear people like give a bear charges,
male climb a tree and the black bay climbs a tree.
Like I mean fucking high do you have seen it?
And then there's the minimum black bear and she's got cubs and she goes so fast
up that dude holy,
he can't climb up a tree to get away from a bear.
Yeah,
get the fuck.
Yeah he had done the big ones just don't want to do it anymore.
But they get still,
I can still do it.
Still do it.
Like the idea is I go to the big ones won't chase you up a tree.
When you see the speed that they go up a tree,
then you can imagine the speed that they come across land.
You know?
And it's just like,
oh cause I always say,
I always tell people about that one that was sleeping on an elk kill,
that I had a grizzly.
We showed that video the other day.
Did Ya?
Yeah,
we showed it on the podcast and I remember I yelled at that Grizzly,
the one that was sleep on the elk carcass and it fucking disappeared so fast.
And quietly,
dude.
And I'm like,
if you don't have eyes on one coming at you,
don't know it's going to come at you until you hit,
until it's on your fucking eat in your face.
They're pads are so soft,
the pads of the feet are so soft in order to sneak up on things.
I remember the first time I went bear hunting with Cam and one was walking in.
He goes right there.
Right there.
I turned to look.
I'm like some noise.
He's like this.
So this is that video.
Yeah,
here it is.
Rude gallon up or run and dude galloping up the true running.
Yeah.
And then fucking scary sheet.
It doesn't stop there.
He ended up coming.
Hang on.
That's a black bear with carbs.
So you can imagine that situation with the grizzly and her cubs.
So fucking scary.
And so that's a color phase.
And we'll target California.
One on the top is the black bear cub.
No,
that's a,
I looked like a full grown black bear of caliphates has got a carb back up the
mountain with her.
Yeah,
that's some crazy shit.
Fucking boy.
Boy Crocodiles don't fucking climbed trees.
That's what I heard.
I heard they're dumb.
When are we doing this?
Someone started the petition.
I fucking,
Joe Rogan needs the hunter Australia.
Yeah.
You keep trying to get me out there.
You've got snakes too though,
bro.
You get sponsors.
Okay,
let's fucking,
let's go over some shitty.
The whole season in Australia,
the whole season in Australia,
I seen two snakes.
One of them not poisonous like a red belly.
Black steak.
Not going to harm your friendly snake lava.
One a barely poisonous snake of a heresy.
Not Very poisoned.
It might kill a kid or a dog fighters.
You guys have though,
the audience know this is a giant
thank you.
Talk to him.
Fucking stay out of it came.
One thing I wanted to ask you about is the thylacine the Tasmanian Tiger.
Yeah.
I read that there was credible reports by people in the woods that they might
have seen.
One.
I wish.
I don't think so,
but it's so remote.
There's so many cameras.
There's guys are scouting cameras that have putting it over da Lowe's and stuff
like places that I would come in the drink.
It was a big animal,
right?
Wasn't it?
Yeah.
Big.
Did they get like a hundred pounds?
I'm like something like that might be a bit bigger than that.
What a cool looking at him,
dude.
And I may always come up and like this,
it is scientists hunt for extinct Tasmanian Tiger after sightings in Australia.
Yeah,
that's probably what I saw.
I wish the,
what does that air article from what year?
Scroll up.
Oh really?
Interesting.
I love the extinction was driven from paypal,
right?
Sort of like,
cause they fucking meat eater.
So they'd come in and start eating cheap or whatever.
They get shot by farmers and stuff like that,
which is a shame.
And I'm sure they didn't realize how doing it at the time,
but that,
you know,
I pushed him to extinction.
You know,
if there's one thing that we should bring back from extinction,
if we,
if it's possible,
I believe they should be brought back if it's possible.
Right.
If they have some DNA because uh,
I mean,
no.
Do I believe,
be nice to have some sort of an animal like that that could knock down some of
the populations go rules and they probably,
I probably wouldn't.
I probably just come in and devastate,
look lives.
Don't stop.
People thought it was a shiny,
yeah.
But let me get back to why you need to come to snakes all year in Australia.
Fucking 17 snakes in the first month in America.
Dude,
17 Schneider got bit the other day.
Did he really?
Yeah,
I think he was in North Carolina or some shit.
I forget where it was.
Somewhere in the south and my buddy Joe's.
Wait,
so this is the first hunt that I did when I come to America.
We flew in the Idaho and we drove straight down to southern Colorado,
the hunt prong on,
and we're driving into the property at like 2:00 AM in the morning and there's a
problem hall and just standing on the side of the road,
you know,
and it's just like a daze,
you know?
So my buddy James pulls up,
he walks over to it and like literally touches it on the head.
Like it's like,
it's just like walking down the road and we're like,
did it get hit by a car next minute?
I seen him jump back.
A rattlesnake had bit the pronghorn and he stood,
he had a leg on ava side of the rattlesnake and it striked him.
It actually strived in twice at miss both times.
I know I had the cake question and I'm like,
did that bite you?
And he's like,
not,
I'm like having to think about it.
Did a fucking bite you?
And he's like,
no,
I didn't cause I watched it in the headlights go for him twice.
And uh,
once we set up camp and went back there and that problem home was decorated,
killed that problem.
Wow.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
Fuck America,
this dryer is so much safer.
A friend of mine was a hiking and he almost stepped on a rattlesnake and he
jumped back and then realized it was a nest of them Holland.
It was a new one surrounding him.
There were all over the place.
He was like,
fuck yeah.
Jumping,
hopping around on one leg after.
Nothing crazy.
I actually had,
um,
as a,
but apparently that happens all the time.
Yeah,
it does.
Yeah.
And trenchless there,
dude.
Everywhere those Tris is walking over the ground.
Everywhere else it,
that's cool.
A bold,
the bold effort to prove the Tasmanian tiger is still out there.
Wildlife Biologists,
forest gallente has brought one species back from the dead and he wants to do
the same with the Tasmanian Tiger.
What the fuck is he brought back from the dead?
This god Damn Frankenstein on the able to plate the Cuban saw Leno.
Dawn is one of the most curious animals and plants.
Small,
shrewd,
shrewd.
I must be shrew.
Like creature memo is a mammal,
but a highly venomous one.
Funny you bring that back in.
The marriage specimen found that was thought to be lost forever.
Then unexpectedly three Rakat just a few years later.
The extinct species mark.
Dot.
So that may be the case with the Tasmanian Tiger.
Hmm.
It'd be awesome.
I hope so.
Okay.
So here it is.
Uh,
Galantes a wildlife biologist made his life mission to search for animals that
have wrongly been deemed extinct.
And among those species on his list at the Tasmanian Tiger,
uh,
Dah,
difficulty leads to,
and he's like,
who the fuck has seen once keeps crowing?
See if anybody like legit scene when he's been traveling around the world
searching for evidence of species like the Tasmanian Devil Paki Lemoore and the
new found land Whitewolf still exist.
100 species deemed extincts worldwide,
annual annually.
This process isn't foolproof in every now and then.
Animals are rediscovered after they were thought to be gone forever.
But proving the animals still out there is no easy feat.
Hmm.
I wonder,
Huh?
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Captured footage of a Zanzibar leopard,
which is thought to be extinct for 25 years due to persecution by local hunters
in the Zanzibar archipelago and Tasmania,
Tanzania rather.
Excuse me.
Wow.
That would be plucking pretty dope if they actually did find that thing.
It's a cool looking animal,
you know.